you have to find something to like in
the language you're learning hi there
steve kaufman here
once again talking about language
learning and i want to talk about what i
would call indirect motivation remember
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notification
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a review we do
appreciate it
so
we know that we need to be motivated i
say this all the time i hope my videos
are motivating
everyone understands that if you have a
motivated student when it comes to
language learning and probably anything
else that
person will learn on their own so
motivation is the key
but how do we get motivated so you know
i was thinking
that uh you know i mentioned i did a
video about my interest in history so
i end up motiva motivating myself to
learn a language because i am motivated
to learn history so in a sense
the learning of the language is almost
an indirect motivation it's not because
i want to learn the language it's i'm
interested in history and therefore i
end up learning the language and you
know that's true with so much in life
if you say
i want to make a lot of money
maybe you first have to
provide a service
which other people are willing to pay
for
or maybe you have to be so skilled at
what you do
that you can generate a revenue stream
or you have to be so knowledgeable in
other words you have to be good at what
you do so that the direct motivation
even though what you want to do out
there is make money you have to first
build up your knowledge base your skill
base
uh and you have to have an attitude that
says i'm gonna deliver
you know value
okay i'm going to if if you want to be a
good
shoemaker to take a simple example you
you can't just be motivated for money
you actually
have to enjoy making shoes
you have to the same if you're in a job
and your goal is to do well in the job
and to be promoted
uh or you're providing some service and
you want to do well with your you have a
company of your own or you're working
for someone else you have to do that job
well that's the direct
objective that you have to achieve you
have to do that well in order to
achieve the sort of indirect
uh
you know
goal that will be the consequence of
your
commitment to doing the job well
or to making sure you have the skills
and the knowledge that you need in order
to achieve that longer term goal even in
personal relationships
you can't just go up to someone and say
i want to be your friend
or i want to be your lover
you first have to invest some time and
effort
into getting to know that person
giving that person a chance to get to
know you
uh they have to like you you have to
like them you know at that level you
build up
a connection
an emotional connection or a connection
of respect
which then
will eat the result the long-term but in
a way indirect result of that person and
you will become friends or lovers or
whatever the case may be
so
there's no sort of short circuit there's
no
you know jumping ahead of yourself you
have to first find that
short term
direct goal that you can focus on that's
going to lead you to your longer term
goal maybe i'm not making any sense here
when i bring it back to language
learning what this means is
you have to find something to like in
the language you're learning
if you cannot find anything to like
anything of interest you're going to
have a very tough time you can't just
say i would like to be fluent in english
because i need it for my job i would
like to be fluent in german or chinese
because it's going to be good for my
career
you actually have to find something
in chinese culture in german culture and
whatever japanese french russian
something that you like
you don't have to like everything
similarly it helps if you find a friend
but you don't have to like all chinese
russians japanese french you name it but
you have to find some people that you
like you have to find some aspects of
the language that you like i often quote
this expression in french la petite
in other words we our appetite
develops as we are eating but let's
assume that assumes that you're eating
something that you like so
uh you know you have to find that
something and that takes a bit of
looking around it takes a bit of
patience and unfortunately it's often
difficult i have found it difficult at
times to find content
that i'm interested in at my level in
the language because i know that if i
can engage myself with
content of interest the learning of the
language look will look after itself if
i do enough listening and reading on
things of interest but i have to find
those things of interest and in some
languages that's difficult to do because
you either have a lot of very
uninteresting beginner material or you
have material that is you know intended
for the native speaker and is too
difficult and it's sort of hard to find
content that's going to lead you towards
the ultimate you know most satisfying
type of material i think that's
something that we want to do better at
link
we're trying to bring in a greater
variety of material from different
sources including youtube
where people just have to click to get
it they don't have to search for it so
that they can kind of just fall into
things
of interest to them
and make that commitment to
learning about those things of interest
that commitment to enjoying
whatever it is that they're interested
in
and then
recognizing that by doing that the
longer term goal of becoming fluent in
the language will take care of itself so
you know it's perhaps a bit of a
confusing rant here but it's something
that i have felt all along in my life
whether in my professional life when
i've often felt if you do your job well
you can't just say i want to succeed i
want to make money no you actually have
to invest in providing
a service
even working for a large corporation you
have to give before you can get you have
to give
more you can't sort of when is coffee
break uh what's in it for me you
actually have to make that investment
in providing
you know service or working hard or
developing your skills in order to
achieve that longer term goal of success
or money or whatever and the same with
language learning you have to commit
yourself to something of interest and
you're devouring those things of
interest and your language skills will
develop as a result so it's something
that i've experienced
i don't know if this makes sense i hope
it is encouraging
and for people who maybe
are at a sort of a doldrum stage where
they feel they're not progressing and
you know they're not
enjoying the process
try a little harder to find something
that's going to turn your crank that's
going to be you know interesting so that
it'll take you
to the final goal which is
the fluency and the comfort level in the
language you're learning
so there you have it thank you for
listening and i'll leave a couple of
videos that might be of interest to you
thank you bye for now